let's get back to the phones the phone
number is six one seven eight three zero
4750 we will go to caller from eight
four five eight four five are you with
us yeah hey what's who's the hello oh
it's mark Benjamin the guy that was out
of breath last time oh good okay it
sounds like you're way more like less
out of breath this time I guess yeah
what's going to finish work that time um
yeah I was wondering have you noticed if
there's an economic crash coming I've
been looking at a lot of podcast that
deals with money and financing stuff yes
and it seems like there's a general
consensus that yeah we're kind of
screwed and I just want your take on
that and have you seen alternative
podcasts except - CNN MSNBC and the
likes yeah that you know that that goes
along that route or like I'm not so yeah
you know - the big three have you seen
podcast that has to deal with money and
do you have any educational tools like
you know books or whether it be the
Australia Australian version of
economics or you know basically a
beginner set to just learn this stuff
okay here's the thing I don't really
watch anything or listen to anything so
I've been doing a lot of reading though
and so a couple disclaimers right number
one from an investment standpoint I'm
against trying to time the market I
think the best investment horizon is
indefinitely I think that you economists
can't really predict where the economy
is going to go you can always look back
and find people who were correct in
their predictions but you're going
backwards right a lot of the people also
made incorrect predictions but then they
were never heard from again
I do have concerns that the regional
housing markets are increasingly
overvalued and in a bubble New York
Boston San Francisco etc although maybe
I'm wrong I think that the stock market
is getting a point of being pretty
significantly overvalued and I think
that that could pop at any time but it
also could be another five years or six
years before it pops and I also had on
following crypto currency valuations as
well and Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin
how high can those go although for years
people have been
saying this is the top it's going to
crash and it just keeps going and going
so yeah if you're asking me am i concern
that there are bubble like sort of
phenomena taking place very concerned do
I think I can predict if and when there
will be a specific pop not really ah
people are calling it to everything
bubble a lot of stuff is over VII is is
I mean overvalued is a relative term but
their nominal values there are lots of
assets that are really really expensive
right now
stocks housing and cryptocurrency are
just three of them and I recently read
the latest version of irrational
exuberance by Nobel Prize winner Robert
Shiller
and if you believe his analysis you
would also be pretty concerned right now
but who really knows fair point
yeah that's actually uh what I wanted to
hear Thanks all right do you have any
yeah in the educational tools you could
do that after the you know since you're
put on time like yeah on the podcast
proper just some educational things that
I could use to just any point of view of
economics whether it be like I said the
Australian school or the I never had a
society in school I know of the Austrian
school is there an Austrian Austrian
Austrian Austrian I said Australian
Austrian school or the arm or just any
different kind that's good for starters
and you know a nice roadmap to whether
to follow to try to get to know this
stuff yeah I mean there's a lot of stuff
there but at least as it relates to your
question I would definitely check out
irrational exuberance and then check out
some of the citations there and you can
kind of start building up a portfolio of
sorts bang yeah all right good very good
to hear from you appreciate it